in 1983 argentina returned to
democracy and at the age of 6 i used
a computer for the first time its love at
first sight i lived in a small
rural town of 2000 inhabitants in the interior of
my country and my primary school had
bought a computer one for
the whole school and the only one in the whole
town
every Saturday morning between the ages of
9 and 14 my parents would drive me 80
kilometers so that I could learn
programming we did not have our own vehicle
and there was no public transport
but since my father is a mechanic  some of
his clients lent us their vehicles
so that we could make that trip when
I was 15 years old I had to start working
and my first job was teaching
computers since that day I have not stopped
teaching and I continue learning computer science
what I am bringing here today to chat with
I want to tell you about two of my
passions: teaching and programming. I am
Yanina Beijing and Saibene. I am a researcher at
the National Institute of Agricultural Technology.
organizer and part of the global ting
dear ladies i am co-founder and child el
atinar i am part of maillard and
co-founder of meta teaching today we are going to
learn about lerner packages to
make interactive tutorials and i hope
we can share the same
enthusiasm that i felt
trips on saturdays to the  tomorrow
the popular wisdom of the
Andean highlands tells us that if I hear something
I forget it
if I see something I remember it but if I do something
I learn it the lerner package facilitates the
conversion of an arm down document
like the one we see on the left in an
interactive tutorial like  This one that we see
on the right we can generate tutorials
on statistics, data science,
programming or whatever you can
imagine, these types of tutorials have
content along with
interactive components that allow us to verify
and reinforce understanding, as we see in
this example tutorial, the content is
you can present images and diagrams in the form of text
we can also
add  download graphic videos and customize
the style of our tutorial
we have a content and progress bar on the left
that allows us to
jump between the different topics and
know how far we are progressing lerner
allows us to learn by doing by
transforming code chams into interactive exercises
by  For example, this exercise already
presents us with the code to make a
graph. If we press the
run code button, the result will be shown
below. If we change something in the
code, for example, we exchange
the variable of the x and y axes and we
execute that change again.  reflected in
the result and if we make an error
such as forgetting to
indicate the x-axis variable and
we execute it, we will be shown a message
indicating that error. These
types of exercises
allow students to test their
knowledge and reflect  based on what they
learned we can also generate
multiple choice questions  indicating
which of the answers are
correct and selecting a
different message to give our
students depending on the option they have
finally chosen, another of the great
advantages of this type of tutorial
is that they can be delivered as an
rr package and then  when installing
it they will appear in the
tutorial tab within the studio or they
can be published as a web page in
this way sharing this material is
very simple
the question now is how did you generate a good
tutorial I am going to tell you my own
secret recipe based on  the teachings
of this book we can think that this
type of educational material has two
main components the context and the
content and the context is going to
strongly influence the final content to
begin to define this context the
first question I have to answer
is for whom am I generating  this
tutorial are people not gowns they are
beginners who have to
know pa  To be able to take advantage of what I
want to teach them, they have
specific needs such as
accessibility,
the first step to start the design is to
know my audience and the people
, a very good tool for
this stage in particular, the second
question I have to answer is that
I want  that they learn with this tutorial and
here I have to define what I am going to teach
I have to write my
learning objectives in this particular stage
it is very useful for me to generate a
conceptual map with all the concepts that
I want to teach and how they are related to
each other
my  The third step is to search and see if there
are already lessons on this topic,
analyzing how other people teach, what
type of tool they use, what is the
sequence in which the
contents are presented, can save us a lot of time
and give us very good ideas, an extra point
if that material is shared.
in a way that can be
finally revised and related to this
previous point  I have to answer the question
that I am going to let other people do
with this material, so here I have to
select a license of use that is
very clear and explicit so that both my
students and my colleagues can know
how to use my material and do it in the
way  correct
yes I know there is a lot of work to do
before writing a single line of
code no don't worry
I have a package that will help you with
this task from meta teaching we generated
a package to read with templates in
Spanish where we also suggest you
select  And what parts can a tutorial have?
Let's see how it works. We
need to have the
lerner package installed, which can be found in Enter, and the
development version
of the lerner package found online is that it
contains the templates in Spanish.
Then, to generate a new tutorial, I'm going
to  select the option file you find
arm down and there I am going to choose front
plane from the list of templates that
appear I am going to e  select
interactive tutorial sections this new
document that is already created in the
header tells us that it is going to be a
lerner tutorial and several
options appear with their parameters and what
each of them mean if
we see there is already a preloaded content
conceptions and  suggestions we are going to
run this document to see that
we have also customized how
the font is presented, the colors, the
links with the visual identity of meta
teaching, you can find how to
customize this using our
css file that is installed together with the
package,
now this first structure that
We propose that all your tutorials
have the learning objectives as the first option
with the idea that
a person who comes across our
tutorial at first sight can
know what they are supposed to
learn with it, also every time
they see in the  box with the apple
we are presenting an example there and
we also make available  links to
places where you can learn more about this
tool or with examples generated by
another person
the second content that we suggest
you present is the type of people
again so that whoever is going to take the
tutorial knows who they thought of when
that content was generated and  we are
putting links to several definitions of typical
people made by the studio and
by meta teaching
finally we present the license of
use and here we explain the difference
between the licenses that are for
educational material the explanation of the
slides two videos and the source code and we
also present  an example
finally as an optional part of
these tools we present a
concept map with an example and links to
where to go to learn more about
concept maps and where you can see and
use various concept maps already
generated in relation to data science
and data science teaching  r
in case you are going to add this
section it is recommended to put it after
the  s learning objectives
finally the other two sections that
appear in this tutorial template
present an example of an exercise with
5 diego and a
multiple choice question defined the context we have
to generate the content of the lesson
there are many processes to generate
lessons of  effectively at least
we are going to have to answer two
questions what is going to be the sequence of
presentation of that content and how are
we going to help our students to
check the understanding of each topic the
formative evaluations presented at
different moments throughout the
tutorial are  An excellent tool
to achieve this objective of reflecting
on what has been learned, checking the
concepts learned and allowing us to validate
the progress and progress that we are
making,
the interactive exercises and the
multiple-choice questions are the two
tools that lerner presents us with
to help us in this task.
chan of code becomes an
exercise  or when I give it a name and
we put the parameter is 6 in true
from there lerner generates a
code box with a run count and
start over button that can have code or
be empty if one writes the code
we are going to have  very useful functionalities
such as suggestions to
complete what we are writing or
it will also mark possible
syntax errors in these exercises as
I was telling you I can present them
blank or I can present them with code and
that code can be complete it can
be a code  functional or may be
incomplete those that present us with a
range of possibilities to carry out
exercises
I can present a functional code and
ask the students to change it
so that it does something else I can present
a code that has an error and
ask the students to  correct
I can present a code with
missing parts as a
faded exercise and which the students have
to complete correctly  Actually
these interactive exercises
also have the possibility that one
adds tips or clues and solutions
to do that we generate another
code chan that will have the same name
but to which we add the word
hyphen of the middle gynt if we want more than
one after  the word sing we are going to
put the middle dash 1 middle dash
2 and so on depending on the number of
clues we want to give the
students to add a solution
we are going to write another code chang
back with the same name and in this
case it will be  script of the middle solution
everything that we put in there will be
presented in a button called gene
in this code box and which we will be
able to navigate the last one that is
presented is the solution we also have the
possibility of copying to the
clipboard  what it says in each clue and
paste it in the code so as not to have to
type it from
the other element that we have to be able to
carry out formative evaluations are the
questions  as multiple choice for this
lerner presents us with the function quiz
question and ansa there we can determine
what is the text of the question what
are the answers with the
mail parameter equal to true we are going to indicate which
is the correct one and in the message parameter
we are going to  To be able to write the text that
we want to give as feedback to our
students,
we also have the possibility to
indicate if we are going to allow the
student to try again in case
he has made a mistake with the parameter a
lowry trail equal to true and we have in the
case of the  questions the possibility to
change the text that the
send answer buttons have and try again
allowing us to put it in our
language we hope that soon we will have
that functionality also in the
code exercises
multiple choice answers are a very good option
to detect common errors that
students tend to commit when they learn
a new topic if we design it
properly  and we include
this type of common error in the incorrect answers,
we will be able to detect it and the
feedback that we give them in the
messages will be much more
significant to help them
learn the subject well and be able to continue on their
learning path,
these are just two of the tools
and we have seen them quickly there are
many other packages that added to
lerner are going to allow us to carry out and
extend the type of feedback and
interaction that we can have with
our students we are going to mention
some for example greidys to
check that the code written is
correct we have a glossary that will allow us to
have definitions of concepts
that are going to be seen during the
parsons lesson to be able to design parsons problems to
diagram to be able to make and
present diagrams and mental maps
among many others
we have reviewed the lerner package to
generate interactive tutorials  and what
elements should not be missing in the design
of a tutorial  If you want to continue
exploring this topic, I leave you the link of
the web page of this talk where there are
blog post tutorial courses and packages
all in Spanish dedicated to this topic
the meta teaching web page where we teach
how to teach for free and in
Spanish and the link  to the
official website of the package that is in English
now they already have a lot of
tools to generate their own
materials and be able to share them with the
entire community
r lastly I wanted to tell you that learning
is acquiring power and it is a very
special power because it is not spent  with use and
once acquired no one can take them away
from me that's why when we teach when we
share our material we make it
reusable we generate it in our language
we are delivering
power I invite you to share your
knowledge to share your power
who knows maybe a girl or a boy  boy in
a small rural town with a
computer in his school find one
of our tutorials and let's open the
door for him  to a new knowledge to a
knowledge that changes your life in a
positive way and why not also ours
thank you very much for listening to me